oh boy trigger trigger trigger trigger
trigger this is bad hey everyone i'm
abby sharp welcome to abby's kitchen
[Music]
we'll be taking a look at miss posh
spice herself victoria beckham but
before we get into it i want to talk to
you about these awesome new shoes from
vessie so i have bought so many shoes
over the years that promise to be
waterproof and fuss-free only to step in
the teeniest little puddle and them to
be ruined for life honestly i'm a mom of
two boys puddles are kind of our jam but
this vessy weekender shoe is 100
waterproof sand proof slush proof and
slip proof so they keep my feet totally
dry and are 100 washable for those
really muddy days or even in the snow
it's actually pretty crazy they're also
sustainably made vegan and made with a
dual climate knit material called
dimetex that keeps them cool in the
summer and warm in the winter and
they're surprisingly stylish for every
day plus they're awesome for travel
because they're so easy to just throw in
a bag or in the wash i basically wear
these every day all spring and summer
long and surprisingly i can still wear
them into the winter with all of our
canadian rain slush and snow they're
super comfortable lightweight and
breathable and they have so many amazing
styles for different looks vessies are
my go-to shoes by my door every day so
check them out at the link below and use
my code to get 25 off your vessy shoes
and you can pause the screen or look at
the description to check out my
disclaimer including a trigger warning
to those with current or previous
experiences with disordered eating so as
always feel free to skip this video if
it's not supportive to your journey and
if you are not already subscribed hit
that sub button and follow me over on
tik tok and instagram abby's kitchen
alrighty folks
let's get into it so back in february
2022 david beckham was a guest on the
river cafe table 4 podcast to discuss
all things food and beverage with
michelin star chef ruthie rogers a true
foodie at heart david shared how much he
loves cooking and eating with the people
he loves which is when he let it slip
about his wife's consistent absence from
this family affair let's take a listen
unfortunately i'm married to someone
that has eaten the same thing for the
last 25 years since since i've met
victoria she she only eats you know
grilled fish steamed vegetables she'll
very rarely
deviate away from there the only time
that she's ever probably shared
something that's been on my plate was
actually when she was pregnant with
harper do you remember it was the most
amazing thing it was it was my one of my
favorite evenings i can't remember what
it was but i know that she's not eating
it since
so
this actually breaks my heart now aside
from the fact that i would legit do
anything anything to share a meal with
david beckham sounds like an adventure
i'm in this absolutely triggers memories
of my own ed days and the impact that my
rigidity had on others not surprisingly
this comment resulted in dozens of
articles suggesting that victoria has an
ed herself and while i'm not diagnosing
anyone i would say that generally
exclusively relying on a small number of
safe foods and avoiding shared family
meals is a common disordered eating red
flag from a nutrient perspective we're
ultimately talking about pretty much the
lowest calorie options available little
to no fat little to no carbs just low
calorie vegetables and lean protein
limited diet diversity risks nutritional
deficiencies and malnutrition and can
disadvantage a healthy gut microbiome as
well it also clearly puts a strain on
social interactions and relationships
and i specifically worry about the
impact on their observing children
especially their daughter harper but
let's find out from victoria herself
what she says she allegedly eats in a
day i'm a very fussy eater i like things
to be cooked in a very simple way i
don't like
oils and butters and sauces
but you guys are always so accommodating
and always
cook the food exactly how i like it very
simple
very clean
incredibly fresh
and just perfect and then you know i
love some steamed vegetables on the side
some balsamic vinegar and then to season
myself so there's no denying that we all
have our food preferences and being a
fussy eater isn't necessarily disordered
but having rigid rules around how food
is prepared is one of the common traits
of an ed especially if those rules
result in the lowest calorie meals
possible it really comes down to
intention and when the quest for
simplicity and eating clean becomes an
obsession and all-consuming it often
teeters into orthorexic territory folks
with orthorexic tendencies often have a
lot of anxiety around how food is cooked
they often choose locale cooking methods
like steaming or grilling over sauteing
frying or roasting in oil they may avoid
oils butters and sauces with unknown
ingredients and they may choose low
calorie sugar-free clean seasonings like
himalayan sea salt hot sauce or vinegars
all of these rules often are used to
maintain a sense of control but long
term they actually have the opposite
effect now some may say that these are
just a preference but celebrities like
victoria have a lot of power and
influence over young impressionable
girls around the world not to mention
the dangerous message that this
communicates to her own children
obviously victoria is a very beautiful
woman and is married to arguably the
most beautiful man in the world
and i do worry that her fans will try to
mimic her preferences to yield similar
life or body results so to most
restaurants i'm probably the worst
nightmare it's not good speaking of
renowned restaurants celebrity chef
wolfgang puck has also confirmed
victoria's restrictive dining habits and
revealed that the spice girl only orders
spinach or steamed veggies with like a
little touch of salt in there whenever
her and her hubby are dining at his
restaurants that is just sad i mean i
have met and worked with wolfgang
himself and he is such a kind and
talented chef no protein no carbs no fat
not even enough calories for a snack it
is so surprising and sad and
disappointed to me that these
restrictive behaviors have been
maintained for so long without any kind
of intervention or personal attempt to
change
so i just decided from that point to
really try and eat in a clean way lots
of fresh vegetables lots of fish i don't
have any dairy at all
i haven't eaten
red meat since i was about seven years
old i eat lots of
fish and i have a very very healthy way
of eating while the quest to eat cleaner
or healthier can often be used to
moralize food and justify rigid
restrictions eating healthy foods is not
inherently disordered if it's
accompanied by an ability to be flexible
and not let these preferences control
your life there's obviously lots of
nutritional benefits to be had in meals
like this so you know we've got
antioxidants and fiber from the veggies
we got high quality protein omega-3 fats
and iron in the fish even from a
nutrition perspective we can also have
too much of a good thing just take the
mercury in fish for a minute i mean sure
some fish are lower in mercury so like
salmon and haddock for example but when
you only eat a handful of foods like
this it's still very possible to exceed
safe mercury levels so for example
eating three servings of salmon or two
servings of haddock in a day would
likely increase victoria's mercury
intake beyond what is considered safe so
this is one of the many reasons why
variety is the spice of life likewise
too much fiber from vegetables can also
result in digestive distress like
bloating constipation and diarrhea
especially if the fiber is coming from
high fodmap vegetables which can be more
difficult for some folks to digest and
the lack of diet variety and calories
can also disrupt our gut microbiome and
digestive enzyme production slowing down
gut motility and resulting in bloating
and other symptoms i talk all about the
impact of eds and digestion in my video
right here but ultimately the disordered
nature of a diet like this really lies
in one's intention one's ability to be
flexible and the impact that it has on
one's life as a whole and the way that i
i'm i'm very very disciplined i work out
a lot and i eat very very healthily
that's just who i am and that's just you
know i'm not the most exciting eater the
thinspo fitzbo wellness culture rhetoric
around discipline and working hard is so
tough it honestly just has to go this is
not discipline that we should be
admiring or trying to emulate this is
restriction deprivation and possibly
overt malnutrition this is the shrinking
of a woman's world physically and
emotionally and don't be roped in by the
fussy eater excuse either you do not
need to be a foodie or an exciting eater
to meet your nutritional needs
especially if those needs are enhanced
by what victoria describes as a rigorous
two hour daily workout routine made up
of a 7k run followed by an hour-long
session with her personal trainer this
is dangerous
research has shown that excessive
exercise without adequate fuel can not
only increase the risk of malnutrition
but it can also lead to muscle wasting
electrolyte imbalances heart issues
injuries and in extreme cases even death
i'm of course mindful of the fact that
victoria works in the fashion industry
where the beauty standard has
historically endorsed a size zero frame
so it is definitely not outside the
realm of possibility that victoria feels
pressured to fit into this beauty
standard and feels the need to adopt
this rigid lifestyle in order to uphold
it but the question is is this even
sustainable i absolutely don't deny
myself anything you know if i wanted
something i'd have it you know i just
it's just who i am you know i have this
healthy
way of eating that works for me so i'm
hearing a lot of this kind of this is
who i am rhetoric which tells me that
this routine has become deeply ingrained
in her identity and again not diagnosing
but this is also a core feature of
orthorexia because folks with orthorexia
moralize food as good and bad so when
they do engage in what they perceive to
be a bad eating behavior they often
identify as bad themselves a perfect
example of this is when david recalled a
singular moment in time when he and his
wife shared a meal that victoria
typically would not eat and then she
proceeded to never eat that food ever
again ugh i am so sad to hear something
like that you know often folks who
struggle with food describe intense
long-term fear and guilt after a
singular experience with a forbidden
food and this fear might become even
more ingrained when someone draws
attention to the slip up as david did in
this case even if it was in a positive
light for him this is why with picky
kids for example we actually don't want
to praise them for eating a scary food
we want to remain as neutral as possible
and the same can be said for adults
struggling with food i know how scary it
is to change an aspect of your life when
you believe it is just synonymous with
who you are but no life is inherently so
small there is so much room in this
world to grow and thrive when we let go
of self-imposed rigid restraints so much
attention on eating fat-free and now
what we know is the complete opposite
actually i mean my diet now consists of
a lot of healthy fats i mean
numerous avocados for example and seeds
and nuts
yes the fat-free craze of the 90s i do
not miss it and the collective
acceptance of fats today just goes to
show why we really should never be
married to any of these changing food
fats having said that i am very relieved
to hear that victoria is insisting on
you know more than just fish and
vegetables and has a little bit more
variety in what she eats so other than
eating more healthy fats she's also
shared with her instagram followers that
she will often prepare a green monster
smoothie with things like apples kiwis
lemon spinach broccoli and chia seeds so
we are getting some carb action from the
fruit some healthy fats and fiber from
the chia and of course micronutrients
and more fiber from the greens i would
love to see more protein here though
maybe by adding in some silken tofu
powdered peanut butter or a scoop of
protein powder especially considering
her activity level we want to ensure
that we are supporting muscle protein
synthesis by getting in enough protein
in the day she's also shared that she
will often have sprouted green breakfast
cereal which is loaded with whole grains
and fiber however one serving is pretty
low calorie as a breakfast meal even
with the unsweetened almond milk that
she adds and the berries in there so to
really bump up that staying power and
add some more calories to this breakfast
we could throw in some more seeds and
swap the almond milk for soy milk which
would help to boost up the calories and
protein
what is your comfort food
and this is where i sound even more
boring in the food department uh what do
i like you know i like
whole grain toast with salt on it it's
that carby thing isn't it it's that
carbohydrate that makes you feel
comforted um i don't want to like yuck
someone's yum here but really out of all
the carby comfort foods out there i mean
i could totally understand maybe some
toasted bread with some salted butter on
top but like just plain bread with salt
ditto for forfeiting birthday cake for a
fruitcake i mean yes to fruit dressed up
like cake for a refreshing weeknight
snack but for like a birthday girl half
the damn cake as for the constant
disclaimer about being a boring eater
again not diagnosing but it's worth
mentioning that it's very common for
folks with orthorexic tendencies to lean
on a more socially acceptable label so
whether that's vegan gluten-free
dairy-free fussy or that they just like
to eat really healthy i know this
because i used all of those myself i
told myself that i preferred fat-free
cheese who prefers fat-free cheese
but this internal and external discord
is often why orthorexia can be so
difficult to recognize and diagnose
because these behaviors are often
normalized in today's wellness culture
obsessed society so i'm gonna say it one
more time for the people in the back i'm
not here to diagnose or imply that
victoria suffers from an ed but i do
think that this interview provides a
typical blueprint for how folks can
engage in dangerous restriction under
the guise of eating healthy being picky
or having a disciplined personality and
what's even worse is that these
attributes are often celebrated and
encouraged as is apparently the case
with victoria so in conclusion if it is
not yet clear i want to reiterate that
often the healthiest seeming regimens
can result in the least healthy lives
because there are very real mental and
physical health risks to making your
food world so small so my hope is that
david can appeal to his wife and they
can look forward to a day when they can
share a meal that is not just steamed
fish and veg and on that note that is
all that i have for you guys again today
if you like this video be sure to give
it the thumbs up leave me a comment
below on who or what you'd like to see
me review next subscribe to the channel
and i'll see you next time on abby's
kitchen bye
[Music]